awareness and fentanyl drug prevention
day so we're taking a look at how those
drugs impact expectant mothers victoria
saha joined us in studio with
information on a program that helps ease
moms off those drugs
the cdc reports the drug epidemic is
growing in the u.s especially among
women when a pregnant woman is using
experts say it not only poses a direct
threat to the unborn baby but could also
play a huge influence on that baby to
start using drugs later in life a
program at roseman university could stop
the cycle
i hope she's okay erin migliera is due
in about a month she was using drugs
around the time she realized she was
pregnant i was honest with my ob gyn and
from the first
get-go and told her
i was on heroin the empowered program at
roseman university helps pregnant women
ease off of drugs with therapy and
medical aid mcgliera is doing her best
to stay clean but her drug use stems
from an early age i mean at 15 i had a
best friend and her mom took a lot of
vikings so
we would steal her pills
farzad kmart a psychiatrist for the
empowered program says drug use often
comes with the stigma some folk might be
using substances to get a feeling of
high or euphoria but oftentimes that
goes away
and it's just to be functioning he says
drug overdose ends up being the leading
cause of death for women who have
reproductive age since 2021 650 people
died from drug overdoses in clark county
237 were women exposure to opioids can
lead to low birth weights right
premature births potentially some fetal
loss and if a pregnant woman was
continuing to use the baby would
potentially be going through withdrawal
symptoms after birth quintilla winbush
has been in recovery for 12 years she's
helping other women at empowered which
she says helps her stay clean and as
long as you're breathing you have a
chance as for mgliera she's taking her
recovery day by day but i'll take a
couple bad days in the lifetime of hell
you know
so this program is free for anyone
living in the las vegas area whether
you're pregnant or postpartum so
typically then victoria how long would a
mother stay in this program so the
psychiatrist that you just heard from he
says whether you're like eight weeks
long up until a year after you give
birth but he said obviously there is
always a chance for relapse even then
you're still welcomed back in to get
that help that you need wow it's
incredible all right victoria thanks